- Welcome, my name is Alan Gerber,
I'm the director of the Institution
for Social and Policy Studies,
and today's event is an
ISPS Democracy event.
ISPS has been holding a
series of events this year,
bringing together experts
from Yale and beyond
to shed light on key questions
concerning American politics,
governance, and democracy.
This is the last event in
the ISPS Democracy Series
this academic year,
and we'll continue with new
events this coming fall.
Before we begin today's event,
I'd like to thank the organizers
who put everything together
and without whose help
we wouldn't be able to hold these events,
that would be Pam Greene, Pam Lamonaca,
Tory Bilski, and Limor Peer.
A little bit about today's logistics,
after introductions of the panelists,
each panelist will talk
for about 10 minutes,
followed by discussion and a
question-and-answer period,
moderated by Steven Wilkinson.
Please save your questions till the end,
during the question and answer period,
you will be able to use
the Raise Hand button
on the bottom of the Zoom screen,
you can also send questions
to the panelists via chat.
Please keep your questions brief,
this event is being recorded,
and if you need technical assistance,
please email isps@yale.edu.
So now I'd like to introduce
all of tonight's panelists at once,
they will talk one after
another without interruption.
Here are tonight's panelists,
or this afternoon's
panelists, first, Elisa Celis.
Elisa is assistant professor
of statistics and data science at Yale,
she is a co-founder
of the Computation and
Society Initiative at Yale,
she's an expert on artificial
intelligence and ethics,
and her research focuses on how algorithms
encode and perpetuate
social and economic biases.
Her work has included
designing voting techniques
that allow for the election
of diverse committees,
including the implementation of,
including the Implementations
of Fair Elections in Switzerland project,
which is what I believe
she'll be talking about,
or focusing her remarks on this afternoon.
Our second speaker is Mark Gorton,
Mark is a founder and chairman
of Tower Research Capital LLC,
one of the leading computerized
trading firms in the world,
Gorton advocates for livable streets,
alternative transportation,
and open government
as the founder and chairman of Open Plans,
a nonprofit devoted to the
pursuit of smart planning
and civic engagement through
media and digital tools.
He is the chairman of Reinvent Albany,
a nonprofit focused on
transparency, accountability,
and good government in New York State.
He is a graduate of Yale University
with a BS in electrical engineering
and an MS in electrical
engineering from Stanford,
as well as an MBA from the
Harvard Business School.
Our third panelists is Hélène Landemore,
Landemore is associate professor
of political science at Yale.
Her new book, "Open Democracy:
"Reinventing Popular Rule
for the 21st Century"
came out this fall at
Princeton University Press,
the book discusses
democratic representation,
and how we could open up
our electoral institutions
to ordinary citizens,
including via what she
terms open mini-publics.
Landemore's previous
book, "Democratic Reason,"
was awarded the 2015 David
and Elaine Spitz Prize
for best book in liberal
and/or democratic theory,
and the Ideas, Knowledge
and Politics Best Book Award
by the American Political
Science Association.
Helene is a policy expert
engaged in several initiatives
to promote democracy
working with governments and
think tanks around the world.
And our fourth speaker is Rob Richie,
Richie is president and CEO of FairVote.
Rob founded FairVote in 1992,
Fair Vote is a nonprofit organization
that researches and
advocates election reforms
to increase voter turnout,
accountable governance,
and fair representation.
He has been involved in
introducing ranked-choice voting
in states and more than 20 cities,
he's a graduate of Haverford College,
where he serves on its corporation.
Our moderator is Steven Wilkinson,
Steven is the Nilekani Professor
of India and South Asian Studies,
and a professor of political science
and international affairs.
He is currently the Henry R. Luce director
of the MacMillan Center for
International and Area Studies.
Wilkinson is a member
of the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences,
and his research focuses on South Asia.
His most recent book, "Army and Nation,"
examined India's success in
managing the colonial army
it inherited in 1947.
He has previously published
"Votes and Violence:
"Electoral Competition and
Ethnic Riots in India,"
which examines the roots of
communal violence in South Asia.
That book was the winner
of the Woodrow Wilson prize
of the American Political
Science Association
for best book on government, politics,
and international affairs.
So with that, let me turn
it over to our panelists
and our moderator,
our first speaker is Professor Celis.
- Hello everyone,
thank you so much for
that introduction, Alan,
it's really great to be
here as part of this series,
and with all these amazing panelists,
I'm really excited about the conversation
that we'll be having today.
So what I wanted to talk about today
is representation in multi-winner voting,
and in particular, a case study
of some work I was really
lucky to be a part of,
which happened in
Switzerland in 2017, 2018.
So what was going on there,
in Switzerland, there's different cantons,
so you think of a canton
kind of a like state,
and the canton of Vaud
had decided by a vote
to rewrite its constitution,
so it was completely
starting from scratch,
and of course, the next question
once you decide to rewrite
the constitution is,
who is actually going to
be doing that rewriting?
And there was a lot of concern
and a lot of debates in the public sphere
as to how one could ensure
that, in this rewriting process,
that interests of every
citizen in the canton of Vaud
will be adequately represented
when rewriting these rules.
So while there, I was
working at l'EFPL at the time
in the neighboring canton,
I was lucky to get connected
with a group of activists
and also various political
parties who were very interested
in the concept of finding
representative ways
to conduct these elections
that still adhere to some
of the usual principles
that we have when conducting an election
in terms of maximizing the number of votes
that we would have.
So in a traditional,
what I would call a traditional
multi-winner voting election,
if you want to, say,
elect four candidates,
maybe you have eight
candidates that are running
and you wanna elect four of them,
normally one person comes in,
they can cast their votes,
the next person comes in,
they cast their votes,
and so on and so forth until
everyone has cast their votes.
In multi-winner elections,
often you get to vote
for more than one person,
so it might be a little bit
different than some elections,
oh, sorry, (indistinct)
than other elections that
you might be familiar with,
but one by one, everyone
casts their votes,
at the end of the day,
you just add them up,
see how many votes each
particular candidate had,
and once you do that,
you sort those votes
from highest to lowest,
and traditionally, the top candidates,
up to however many you need
for your committee, win,
so if you're electing four candidates,
here are your four winners of
this mock cartoon election.
So the problem,
sorry, I don't know what's
going on with my slides today,
so the problem with this
is that this can result
in very disproportionate
groups of candidates
that are elected with respect to criteria
that you might care of with
respect to our presentation,
such as gender or age or race or locality.
So the question was,
how can we have an election
that still satisfies
some representation type of constraints?
So for example, one could have a criteria
that says we would want
equal, or roughly equal,
numbers of men and women to win.
So if you have one criteria, such as this,
and you can partition your candidates,
it's pretty easy to
know what you should do,
you just take, say,
you can, of course, satisfy
these constraints trivially
by taking any two women and any two men,
in this toy example,
but that's, of course,
not what you want to do,
what you want to do is take the two women
that have the most votes
and the two men that have the most votes,
and that seems reasonable, right?
You're satisfying this criteria,
but you're also adhering
to this prioritization
of the votes, right?
You're still speaking to what the people
are voting for, right?
So the goal overall in
these types of question
is select the committee
with the most votes
that still satisfies the
kind of diversity constraints
that you would care about,
the problem is that if you
have more than one criteria,
this becomes computationally hard,
and that's the perspective
that I approach it from,
my background is in computer science,
I'm in the statistics and
data science department
here at Yale,
and that's basically when I was able
to step in and play a role,
the question is, how can we
balance multiple criteria?
Because we care about representation
across many different dimensions,
and along with some colleagues,
I was able to work on this problem
and come up with some really
interesting technical solutions
in the vein of approximation algorithms
that help you come up with,
help you design this in a way that,
once you collect all of these votes,
you can do exactly what you wanted, right?
You satisfy all these criteria,
and conditioned on satisfying
all of the diversity and
representation criteria
that you care about,
you return a committee,
you produce a committee that
has the most number of votes,
and so it was really
exciting to be a part of this
and actually be able to have
this type of solution implemented
and used in this particular election.
Of course, that is just one piece, right?
So one piece was the design of
the approximation algorithm,
thinking of this computationally,
looking at the algorithm design,
and it's a very interesting piece,
but it's just one part of the equation.
I think a very large part of the equation,
which several of my co-panelists here
would be able to speak more to,
is what are the good ways
to design this process as a whole, right?
So who is even deciding what
are the right constraints?
What are the right categories?
How do we even decide what
is a representative sample?
And what we...
The process that was used
in this particular case
study that I'm talking about,
what we did was a two-stage process,
so first, well, two (indistinct)
process leading up to that
in terms of different community events,
a lot of discussion that
happened in the public realm,
but basically, when it came down to votes,
first, a set of constraints were proposed,
so should the committee be
representative across gender,
should it representative across race,
should it representative
across religion, et cetera,
so different places where one
could enforce representation,
so first, one voted on the criteria
and what that would look like,
and then about a month later
was the actual election
that ran just to vote on
the candidates themselves,
so that's how this
particular election worked,
although there would, of course,
be many potentially different ways
to design this process and to
elicit those initial votes.
In this particular case,
there was, of course,
a canton as a whole,
but there were different regions
within each canton that were
each having an election,
so it was really kind of eight elections
that ran in parallel,
and the biggest one was
a committee of size 18
that was being elected from 50 candidates,
and each voter could
vote for 18 candidates,
and the type of criteria that
were elicited via this process
that they agreed upon was one for gender,
one for age, and one for locality,
so there's a lot of political tension
between people living in cities
and people living in the countryside,
so that was one of the places
in which diverse
representation was required
in this election,
and then once that was satisfied,
we could use our type of technical
for a multi-winner voting solution.
So I just wanted to
present this case study,
I think there's, again, many
different people on the panels
that can speak to different parts
of this process as a whole,
and I look forward to
hearing your questions,
and I'm happy to dive into
any more of the details
on the different aspects of this.
On the technical side, I
worked with Lingxaio Huang,
Vijay Keswani, and Nisheeth Vishnoi,
and then our partners in particular
was a nonprofit called Appel Citoyen,
with Florian Evequoz and Johan Rochel,
so I just wanted to say my
thank you to them as well,
it was really a fun and exciting
project to be a part of,
and I'm happy to share with you.
Thank you.
- Hi, I'm Mark Gorton.
I'd like to first thank Alan
for inviting me to participate,
and everyone who's put this together,
it's really an honor for me
to be included in this group
and be asked to talk.
I'm gonna speak about the
problems with mass elections
and present what I call
the micro-democracy/working
group alternative.
So I have been quite involved
in politics or civic engagement
in New York City and New
York State for quite a while,
and I have seen
the structural problems that exist,
and it seems like good government groups
are always fighting a system
where the entrenched interests
are working for themselves
and not in what you would
think of the interests
of the general public,
and after fighting time and again
and through election cycle again,
it just seemed like the
structure of the system
was so fundamentally flawed
that I began to think
that the problem comes
down to the very nature
of mass elections,
and I'm sure a lot of
people are very aware
with lots of problems that we have
with poor-quality leaders
and corruption in the system,
and I just see time again
the corrupting nature of elections
as candidates are
required to make promises,
get money, build coalitions,
and so, frequently, what you
have is sort of good people
who are forced to corrupt
themselves just to get elected,
and that creates
all sorts of issues
and all sorts of corruptions and problems
we have in our government,
and I'm sure I don't
have to tell people here
about lots of these.
So I started thinking
about how it would be possible to correct,
to build an alternative
system that both has,
is representative and
captures democratic intent,
but also is resistant to corruption
and attracts and selects good leaders,
and after thinking about it,
I have formulated some ideas,
which I will share here,
so it's basically based
on a working-group system,
so rather than having mass elections
where everybody in the population
is expected to participate
in a very, very thin and trivial way
in lots and lots of elections,
and, as most people
know, in most elections,
your vote really somehow
doesn't matter very much.
The concept of democratic participation
would be shifted towards
one that is much chunkier
of occasionally participating
in a working group
that would be taking a
very specific decision,
so rather than having a small say
in lots and lots of decisions,
really, this focused attention
is partially designed
to get a better outcome.
So I imagine a three-step process,
so the first step is an election,
and it's actually, but
it's a micro-election,
a very, very small election among a group
of perhaps somewhere between
40 and 100 neighbors,
so this election is meant
to be not very daunting,
easy to campaign for,
among people that are hopefully well-known
to the candidates,
and the reason that I had thought
that having these
micro-elections would be good
is because the fact is that most people
are not very engaged in
politics and civic events,
and rather than, you know,
some people are just too busy,
don't have time,
so rather than trying to get people
who are not particularly
engaged to be engaged,
that would have a chance to get people
who could be representative
of their own community
and who would care to be engaged,
and still having these
very small elections
would give you a fairly
good representative sample
of the population,
so basically, at the end of
this process of micro-elections,
about 1% of the population
would be chosen as micro-representatives
or people that would be available
to serve on working groups later.
So then the next step would
be staffing working groups,
and this would be done randomly,
so really, these working groups would work
much more similarly to the
way juries function right now
where people are chosen at
random to participate in a jury,
this, people would be chosen from random
of the pool of micro-representatives
to participate in these working groups,
and then the process that I imagine
for choosing office-holders
would be decomposed,
and the example that I'm presenting here
is something that I
think of as an election
for a reasonable-size office,
so maybe a member of the
House of Representatives
or a governor of a moderate-sized state
or a mayor of a city,
this process could be scaled,
I mean, obviously, a process
that involves 100 people
is too much to choose members
of a local school board
and maybe too few to choose
the president of the United States,
but still, these process can be scaled
for the appropriate size,
but the important thing
are the steps that I have
decomposed it to here,
so the three steps are
choosing the candidates to be considered,
doing research on those candidates,
and then finally, choosing
the final office holder,
and a big part of the reason
that I am suggesting breaking it up
into different job functions
is to reduce the risk of corruption.
I think it's quite possible,
again, particularly for large
and high-stakes elections,
that having a small number of people,
I mean, maybe as a few as 100
who all a very strong say
in the process of choosing
the final office holder,
those people obviously
could be easily targets
of bribes and threats
and things like that,
again, if you're talking about choosing
the mayor of a small town,
maybe these are not really issues,
for much bigger offices,
much more so for if you're talking
about choosing the president,
you might wanna choose the people
and quickly sequester them away
so they couldn't be corrupted,
but really, a big part of why I think
this could be a superior solution
is that you have people who have the time
and a reason to focus,
a reason to invest time and effort
in really becoming educated
about the people who are involved,
putting in time to be thoughtful,
one of the great challenges
with mass elections
is that you have so many people
who have so little stake in the system
that it's very hard for them
to merit investing the time
to be making an informed decision,
so by having these much more engaged,
informed, deliberative bodies,
the hope is that the,
the choice that will be made
will be much more rational
and you have people who
are much more engaged,
and a lot of the
techniques that we see now
in terms of mass disinformation
and these social media campaigns,
you know, all the different things
that are distorting the
democratic process now,
this process that I'm proposing
is somewhat immune, or at
least resistant, to that.
Now, there are other corrupting vectors
that could be used to attack this,
but I do think that the fact
that you bring random people together
for a brief period of time
then disband these
committees when they're done
means that the target
for any sort of corrupting attack
is really ephemeral,
and it can be that hopefully
would make this whole system
very resistant to corruption,
or at least fairly resistant,
which I think is really
one of the main things
that I've been shooting for
in my design of this system.
So thank you very much for
taking the time to listen to me,
I, as opposed to everyone
else involved here,
I'm an amateur, I'm not
involved in academia,
but I really am interested
in working on these ideas,
so if anyone is interested in engaging,
I'd be really happy to talk to people,
here is my information,
and I hope to be able to
make some connections,
so thank you very much.
- Hi everyone, this is my turn,
I'm Hélène Landemore,
I'm not going to use a PowerPoint
because I suspect that the reason
I don't need a PowerPoint is that my idea
is much simpler than what's
been presented so far.
Instead of offering what I see
as complicated epicycles to
salvage the current system,
I propose changing the system altogether.
The main problem I see
with what we call political
representation today,
as I had diagnosed in my
book, "Open Democracy,"
is that this type of representation
and the regime form it corresponds to
is fundamentally exclusionary,
electoral representation,
as Aristotle, Montesquieu,
and then Brennan more recently
have told us over and over again,
is an aristocratic selection mechanism
based on an in-egalitarian
principle of distinction.
Why?
Because elections only empower
those who stand out socially
in the eyes of most,
this is why the Greeks of classical Athens
did not use elections to
staff political offices,
instead, they used a lottery-based system
that distributed power equally
among the individuals who
qualified as citizens.
Citizenship was defined in
exclusionary ways, it's true,
in ancient Greece,
but distribution of political
influence among citizens
was perfectly inclusive at a given time.
We modeled, by contrast,
we invented democracy
in a very elitist form,
choosing elections as
the primary mechanism
to select representatives,
meaning to select people who
are going to stand for us
and make decisions on our behalf,
and even as the franchisers
kept expanding since the 18th century
and the restrictions
on who can run for
office have disappeared,
access to power in electoral democracies
remains limited to those
who can win elections,
again, because they have attributes
that are not readily
distributed in the population,
say, charisma, height, intelligence,
but also money and connections.
Meanwhile, other people's power,
perhaps 95%, 98% of
the rest of the people,
is limited to those enfranchised
people every four years.
"So why is that a problem?" you might ask.
Well, not only does it mean
that we do not live in
authentic democracies,
since for most of us,
representative democracy means being ruled
and almost never ruling,
but electoral democracies tend to suffer
from the blind spots
one would typically expect
from oligarchic regimes.
They have a tendency to ignore,
among others, their poor,
their young, their minorities of color,
and the losers, they can't make policies
like free trade or austerity measures.
This is so because these people
rarely make it to
positions of elected power,
or any power at all, for that matter.
Yet, if these people are not in the room
where laws and policies get
deliberated on and made,
not only do their interests
fail to be taking into account,
but even if they are taken into account,
such interests are not as
likely to be served properly
for lack of a proper
first-hand perspective
applied to explaining and promoting them.
In the U.S., these blind
spots of electoral regimes
have harmed the welfare of
the African-American community
since the birth of American democracy,
and more recently, the
welfare of the working class
since the rise of
neoliberalism in the 1980s.
In France, similarly,
a government consisting
of largely urban, educated individuals
who live in city center
and perhaps bike to work,
were shocked to discover that
the well-intentioned fuel tax
in November of 2018
could generate the
sometimes violent pushback
of peri-urban, lower middle-class people,
causing the rebellion now
known as the yellow vests.
This elitist, biased electoral
democracy cannot be fixed,
it is intrinsic to elections
and they get worse with time
or under conditions of
growing economic inequalities,
it can be mitigated,
but it cannot be fixed.
My solution consists in finally
facing up to this reality,
to this fact,
and considering alternative
modes of representation
that are more inclusive and egalitarian,
namely, more democratic in
the proper sense of the term.
The innovation here is both
conceptual and institutional,
I propose to decouple the idea
of democratic representation
and the idea of electoral representation,
these are not synonymous,
or in other words, I propose
to render elections optional
to the concept of
democratic representation.
Second, I develop a division of democracy
that I call open democracy,
partly based on this new,
non-electoral concept of representation,
and I argue that only in such a regime
would we be truly political equals
and able to avail ourselves
as the entire collective
intelligence of society.
An open democracy is structured
by five institutional principles,
participatory rights, deliberation,
the majoritarian principle,
democratic representation,
and transparency,
but here is not the place
to develop the full
vision for open democracy,
so let me simply focus
on this idea of democratic representation
as distinct from electoral representation,
and on the core institution
of an open democracy
that this democratic
representation translate into,
namely, the open mini-public.
A central contender for a type
of political representation
that is inclusive and
accessible to all equally
is indeed what I call
lottocratic representation,
that's representation
based on random selection,
or selection by lot.
Examples of lottocratic bodies
are the Council of 500
of classical Athens,
as well as these lots in our juries,
and under modern circumstances,
things like citizen juries,
consensus conferences,
deliberative polls, citizens'
assemblies, and the like,
all qualify as type of mini-publics
because they aim to present
a miniature portrait of the people,
although technically, this is
only true of very large ones.
So what if, instead of elected chambers,
we used randomly selected ones
to set the agenda for the
polity, or even make laws?
The advantage of random
selection is twofold,
first, it creates a much more egalitarian
distribution of power,
if we institutionalize such bodies
at all levels of the polity,
and perhaps also in firms,
hospitals, and schools, say,
and with enough rotation,
all of us would have an equal
chance, and a real chance,
of exercising real power
over the course of our life,
not just consenting to
it at regular intervals,
and if this is true, I think
even if we need to implement
stratified random sampling
rather than pure sortition,
because for smaller bodies,
this is the only way to get
the categories we care about
represented somewhat fairly.
It is, in that sense, a
democratic improvement
over elected parliaments,
where most of us, we never set foot
Second, a random selection
or stratified random sampling
reproduces in small
the cognitive diversity
of the larger group,
namely, the different ways of thinking
present in the population,
this minimizes the risk of blind spots
and increases our chances
of making good decisions for the group.
I thus propose as the heart
of a considerably reformed
democracy the open mini-public,
a body of a few hundred people
forming a new kind of
representative legislative body,
this body is open, I specify,
because in order to avoid closure
and disconnection with the larger public,
its deliberation must remain accessible
and visible to the rest of the public,
including interest groups,
who can input those
deliberations at any stage,
for example, via the use of
online crowdsourcing platform.
This allows the smaller body
to tap the information
of the larger public,
but also promotes a larger public debate
about the nature and content
of the deliberation going on,
which is important for the
legitimacy of the mini-public
to begin with.
So it's highly unlikely at this stage
that a legislative open
mini-public of this kind
is going to replace elected assemblies,
though some have been calling
for something like this,
and I personally think that
this is the more coherent ideal,
as I mentioned.
Again, at this stage, what
we can realistically consider
is augmenting electoral democracy
and electoral assemblies
with such lottocratic bodies
to make them more truly,
to make the whole system
more truly representative.
Even if no replacement occurs,
though, again, some people
have called, for example,
for replacing the Canadian
senate with a lottocratic body,
or the House of Lords
with a lottocratic body,
or the (speaks French) in
France with a lottocratic body,
the change still implies
a significant redistribution
of power from elected chambers
to the new open mini-publics.
One could imagine having
an openly public legislate
specifically about environmental issues,
issues around climate change
or issues about the future,
and we could also envisage giving them
the power to veto certain bills
coming from the other chambers
when they run against it's own mission.
or one could imagine ad hoc mini-publics
being convened on certain issues
at the initiative of either
the government, parliament,
or the citizen themselves by other right
known as citizen initiative.
In the latter case,
the recommendations of
the one-off mini-public
would have to be made at
least somewhat binding
on the other legislative institutions
because we know from experience
otherwise, they largely get ignored.
This proposal, even in its more reformist
and complementary version
may seem farfetched to you,
but in fact, a lot of
experimentations around similar ideas
have been underway for over 20 years.
A recent OECD report titled,
"The Deliberative Wave"
has documents around 287
deliberative experiments
with all the mini-publics of
that kind around the world
over the last 20 years,
and just in the last decade,
there's been a surge as well.
Among the more salient example,
I'll just mention, in 2017 in South Korea,
a citizens' assembly of
randomly selected citizens,
which was given the final say
over the decision whether or not
to continue the construction
of two nuclear reactors,
a decision that was actually implemented
over the country president's
preferred choice.
In 2017 as well, Mongolia passed a law
requiring that a deliberative poll be held
prior to constitutional amendments.
In late 2018 in Ireland,
a popular referendum
validated the recommendations
of a specially convened citizens' assembly
of 99 randomly selected citizens
to decriminalize abortion,
and this was followed by a referendum
in which this proposal approved.
Most recently in France,
the Citizens' Convention for Climate,
which I've studied and closely observed,
made 149 recommendations about how to curb
greenhouse gas emissions in
a spirit of social justice,
half of those proposals
have now been turned into regulations,
and many of them are currently
influencing various bills.
At the smaller scale,
regions are now interested
in using mini-publics to set the agenda
of the legislative bodies,
as has been the case for a year
in the German-speaking region
of Belgium, for example,
where they had a council of
24 randomly selected citizens,
a very small jury-like body
that could convene larger
citizens' assemblies
and set the agenda for
the local parliament.
Brussel, the city of Brussels
now is developing so-called
deliberative committees
to help guide public policy.
At the global level,
engineers and academics
are now organizing,
it's coming up this fall,
the first global climate assembly
to accompany the negotiations
around the Conference of the
Parties in 2021 in Glasgow.
So I'm looking forward
to seeing more of this
being tried out in the
United States as well,
I believe this is the only way to aim
for a more democratic kind
of political representation.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you, it's terrific
to be part of this,
I'm Rob Richie.
I often feel I'm talking about change
in a way that's bolder than most people,
but I feel in this set of presentations,
maybe I'm being moderate
by only being for proportional voting
for U.S. House elections
and widespread use of
ranked-choice voting.
I will say there's
something important to me
about the electoral process
that doesn't displace some
of these other bold ideas,
but also means that the seeking
consent of the governed,
reaching out to people
in a process where there's full debate
is something that I
certainly wanna make sure
stays part of any system that we have.
I'll go ahead and share my screen
and get into my PowerPoint here.
So what I'm gonna zero in on
is those ideas of what
we can do statutorily
in the United States,
and I wanna get at it through the lens
of why it is particularly important now.
We are in time of sort of heightened,
deep political polarization,
and to us, it's really grounded
in the use of winner-take-all voting,
so election rules drive behavior,
we don't think this is,
what we're seeing in Congress
and in many of our elections
is because of bad people
who decide to run,
but they have certain incentives
that drive what happens.
You can certainly see in very basic ways
that the election rules drive behavior in,
just use a couple examples,
when you're having presidential
nomination processes,
Iowa goes first,
and lo and behold, about 50% of events
in the first run-up to the year
before the nomination contests take place
take place in Iowa.
The swing states in the
general election for president
are the ones that are tightly contested,
others are not,
and about 98% of campaign events and ads
are earmarked for voters
in those 12 states,
not because the candidates don't care
about the rest of the voters,
but it doesn't affect
whether they win or lose.
So winner-take-all means 51% of votes,
which, of course, is a majority,
wins 100% of representation, 49% wins 0,
and if it gets a little bit more tilted,
55% or so, it's essentially a done deal,
that if you're comfortably ahead
or hopelessly behind, you can't win.
So there's a good book by Lee Drutman
called "The Doom Loop,"
and I sort of walk through
how things are playing out,
but we're in a cycle
that's reinforcing itself
and things are getting worse and worse,
so first, most states and
districts have a partisan tilt,
that's natural that the parties
aren't so evenly placed,
I mean, as political
polarization increases,
that winner-take-all rule
means that partisan majorities
decide more and more outcomes,
general election doesn't really matter.
So to win the election,
most candidates don't really need
to worry about the general election,
they only need to worry
about how they get nominated
to be part of the majority
party in that area,
so they only need to cater
to those relatively small
percentage of voters
that participate in partisan primaries,
there was a recent study,
it's about 10% of voters
are really deciding
the great majority of outcomes.
And for some reason...
Okay, there we go.
And then as a result,
Congress is now more prone to gridlock,
and you can see just how
difficult it is for the parties
to take on anything
substantive and challenging
and actually do things together,
their base doesn't want them
to do it, they're fighting,
they can get things done when
one party runs everything,
but even that can be challenging,
but certainly, when they're divided,
it gets really challenging,
these disputes lead to
greater partisan ill will,
the partisan voters therefore
become more fearful and angry
of the base,
and so the cycle continues,
and so things just keep
getting worse and worse.
So how can we sort of get out of this?
We first have to start with the fact
that we're in a very difficult place
in a winner-take-all election system,
more than 80% of congressional races
are just fundamentally safe
because of that winner-take-all dynamic.
FairVote does a report
we started way back about 25 years ago
called "Monopoly Politics,"
but our insight was that
we could make projections
in the great majority of House races
knowing nothing about the current cycle,
just based on whether the
incumbent was a decent incumbent,
and which you can measure
in kind of some simple ways,
and the tilt of the districts,
and we've been doing this for years,
we could project the 2020 House
races in about 85% of races
within a week of the 2018 elections
and essentially get all
but one or two right,
in some cycles, we get
every single one right,
so it means that whatever campaigning
happens in those districts doesn't matter.
If you look at the underlying
nature of districts
and note the pattern here,
it isn't just happened
when districts are drawn,
it's happening between
cycles of districting,
that districts are becoming
less and less competitive,
and you're seeing voters
split their tickets less
and they are voting more consistently,
so back when I helped
start FairVote back in '92,
at that time, in Congress,
about 112 seats had members
who represented a district
won by the other major party's
presidential candidate,
so more than a quarter of seats
were held by someone who
was of a different party
than the candidate that
carried that district
in the presidential race,
we're now down to that's only 16 people,
less than 4%, so almost total alignment,
the U.S. Senate is the same way,
state legislative races have
become more and more lined
up with presidential races
just based on the partisan
label drives behavior.
At the same time,
the country's going through
this Big Sort concept,
the idea that people are
becoming more alike politically
with others where they live,
and you can measure that,
again, this isn't gerrymandered,
this is just sort of counties,
and counties have become
more and more aligned
with one party or the other
at the same time that people
are splitting their tickets
less and less,
and you can look at
sort of the red-blue map
if you have our simplistic
system that we have
where it's just Democrats and Republicans,
and there's much more coherence
and sort of solid blocks of color,
which also plays out in
predictability of races.
So let me talk about the
two ideas that we focus on,
both of these are statutory,
both of these are getting
increasing attention,
ranked-choice voting's
getting a lot of use,
so that is the idea of replacing
when you vote for one person,
or you vote at all, essentially,
you go for a ballot where you
can just vote for one person,
a single-choice ballot,
sort of all or nothing,
you either give a vote to someone or not,
with a ranked-choice ballot,
and I'll explain what that means,
but it's something different,
and then you replace
the winner-take-all rule
with a proportional system,
kind of like what we heard about
was going on in Switzerland,
and indeed, is used in most
countries in some form.
So a ranked-choice ballot,
here's a very basic one,
instead of just ticking off one candidate,
you get to say, "Hey, here's my candidate
"who's my first choice,
"but I actually do have something to say
"about other candidates,"
in this case, the person's
saying Brown's our first choice,
Castro's our second, Adams' our third,
this is simple and easy for voters to do,
it was introduced, say,
in five states' democratic parties,
used in presidential primaries last year,
first time, vote-by-mail ballots,
99.9% of people cast a valid ballot
and a great majority of
people ranked more than one.
So here's what you do
when you count them up,
so you add up the first choices only,
so you look at that ballot and
you only count first choices.
If someone wins more
than half of the vote,
you have a first-round winner, that's it.
If not, the candidate that is
in last place is dropped out,
and you're only counting
that ballot's candidates
for your next choice,
so everyone has only one vote that counts,
but you get a backup if
your favorite is out,
so in this case, it goes down to three,
you still don't have a majority winner,
you knock out the last-place candidate,
and voila, you have somewhere
over half the votes,
and that's all there is to it.
So what does this mean politically?
So one is that it creates this space
to have more than two chances
and not have this immediate
finger-pointing dynamic
where like, "Why is that person running?"
and, you know, right now,
you're having kind of a
debate on the Republican side
where some people love Donald
Trump, some people don't,
and there's sort of talk about whether
there should be another party,
and there's a lot of them saying like,
"Well, we can't do that
because we'll split the vote."
You know, Ralph Nader
running as a Green Party
or Ross Perot as an
Independent or what have you
that they don't talk
about whether that person
has an idea that's different
or a political philosophy
that should be represented,
it's just the dynamics
of you can't have more than
two people in our politics,
if you break that down, you
begin to break down the binary.
What it means kind of
politically with outcomes
is that candidates,
and you really see this
particularly well in city elections,
we have lots of good data
from cities and primaries,
and it encourages candidates
to engage with more voters,
run more positive campaigns,
not everyone being
lovely to everyone else,
but it incentivizes reaching out,
and the winners typically
get affirmative preferences
from 65, 70% of the voters,
which is an indication of
that sort of reaching out,
and again, it's being used quite a bit
in the United States now,
we're up to two states using
it for president and Congress,
90-plus colleges and universities
sort of do it on their own in 20 cities,
we might see as many as
10 more cities using it
in Utah this year.
Let's now turn to multi-member districts,
now, we see a lot of
multi-member districts
in local elections in the United States,
you still see a number of
state legislatures with them,
I actually have three House
members here in Maryland,
we heard some about them in Switzerland,
now, there's a lot of ways
that you can use multi-member districts,
but the basic idea is you change
from having only one person
trying to represent everyone
in a geographic area,
so Congress or the U.S. House,
not a single U.S. House member represents
any of the same people
that anyone else does,
and you go to having, say, in
this example in Massachusetts,
you go to having bigger districts
with more representatives,
so it's three, three,
and three in this case,
if we use the ranked-choice system,
single transferable vote in
our classical terminology,
it only takes 50% to win,
it takes them a little
over a quarter of the vote
to win one out of three seats,
50% to win two, more than
75% to sweep all three,
that high percentage of what
it takes to win all three
has a really interesting impact.
So what does it mean for
polarization and representation?
David Brooks wrote a great column
in "The New York Times"
a couple years ago,
(indistinct) "One Reform to Save America,"
this is this Fair Representation Act,
which has been introduced
and is about to be (indistinct) again,
and what it means for polarization
is that, really, there's no
safe seats anymore, right?
So all that kind of
blocked out of the country,
that stark red and blue,
in fact, pretty much every single district
is gonna have both
parties having the power
to help elect someone from it,
you can have Republicans in
New York City and other cities,
Democrats in rural areas,
and different kinds of Democrats
and different kinds of Republicans,
third parties and Independents
have a challenge to win,
but they can hold the
major parties accountable
in a different kind of way,
and then you have a Congress
that has a much more centered
political center represented,
but also, it has sort of
vibrant representation
of left and right,
and of course, we're not linear that way
and it's sort of a more
three-dimensional reality
that that would allow it
to function differently.
So it was H.R. 4000 in the last Congress,
sort of to sum up the
representation impacts,
our simulations show that
with this system in place,
every single state that
has at least three seats,
you would have every voter
probably end up being represented
by candidates from both major parties,
and again, those independents
and third parties
having a fighting chance,
women, we see a dramatic
increase in representation,
there's a lot of good
data that just showing
going to multi-member districts
would change that to the more fluid nature
of choice and competition
would very likely lead
to a significant boost
just from the get-go from this system,
and people of color would have
really dramatically
different opportunities
to both participate and win,
one way of showing that is that
you can go from California,
a whole line of states all the
way to my state of Maryland,
and every single one of those states,
every person of color
would have the opportunity
to join with other like-minded voters
to help elect a candidate of choice,
which would be quite dramatic
when you think that that's the South
and that's where part of the regions
that have been so racially polarized.
So I look forward to chatting
about it with people,
I'm Rob Richie,
and I'll pass it on to my next person.
- Okay, thanks very much.
So these have been great,
one thing, I wanted to
remind people to please use
the Raise Hand button on the
bottom of the Zoom screen
to ask your question,
or else the chat function,
I'm gonna collect those
and then ask questions,
but to get us started,
I think there's one question
I'd like to ask all the panelists,
which is, how much do you hope
that these different electoral systems
will make a difference in
terms of overall outcome?
So if we look around the
world, we see big differences,
certainly across different
electoral systems,
but I'm struck by the fact
that even within places that
have the same electoral system,
there's just enormous variation
in terms of some of the negative things
that people have said that they wanted
via a fix in democracy,
but that tells us that electoral rules
can make a difference,
but not all the difference,
and I wanted to get some
sense from the panelists
of how much of a difference they think
that changing to these
incredibly interesting systems
will make to outcomes they care about,
and then secondly, whether
they think there's any cost
to the particular mechanisms
that they're talking about,
is there a trade-off, and
how do they see the downside?
So we can go in the order
in which we started,
and then while that's happening,
I'll look at people's comments in the chat
and we'll get ready to
call on people in the chat,
and when I do call on you,
we're going to ask you to go live
and ask the question yourself on video,
and so please be ready for that.
Okay, Elisa, first to you.
- Yes, thanks so much, Steven,
and thanks again to all the panelists
and everyone for being here.
Yeah, that's an incredibly
interesting question
and I think it's very hard for me
to say exactly how much
change it can affect.
I do think it's, of course,
who is setting the rules
and setting the tone for our country
is incredibly important,
so I do think that it,
changing how we elect people,
changing if we elect people,
all of these things can
have incredible impact.
Now, quantifying that in some way,
I'm not quite sure how to do that,
and while I do think there is a cost,
I think that cost is just
in terms of time and effort
and more participation,
which sounds like a cost, right?
There's more work that has to be done,
but that naturally is more
work of involving more people,
involving everyone into the whole process
that is affecting their lives
and is affecting our future,
so it's a good cost to pay.
If the cost is more people
have to participate,
then that's exactly what we wanna do.
Thank you.
- Mark?
- I mean, obviously, the system
is large and complicated,
and no one change is enough in any way,
a large part of what I
have been thinking about
has to do with just the
incentives of elected officials
because most people
tend to respond to their incentives,
and if something helps them personally,
they're inclined to
move in that direction,
and so I've been personally focused
on trying to think about how
to mitigate bad incentives in the system
and create good incentives,
but there is obviously so many pieces
to how the government
is structured and runs,
and I think that we're
really at a point where,
I mean, essentially,
the systems that we're
running with today in the U.S.
are 100 or 200 or more years old,
and there have been so many changes
to society, to scale, to technology,
I actually think there are,
you know, the possibility
of openness and transparency
due to new computer technology
means that it's possible for people
to have much more insight into the details
of how government works and
to perhaps micro-target it,
so I think there's a whole,
I mean, I'm hoping in the next generation
we'll see a range of new ideas
and a whole range of changes
to improve the efficiency
and honesty of the system
because right now, government doesn't,
you know, it kind of clunks along,
but it is by no means
working well in most places.
- [Steve] Thanks. Helene?
- So I think any of these proposals
are improvement on the status quo.
I do feel, though, that it will create
more visible diversity,
but without much of a,
or not enough of a committee
difference, if you will,
in the sense that at the end of the day,
elections remain, as I insisted, elitist,
so you will bring about
more people of color and women,
the sort of, like, demographic
categories we care about
because they're easy to
understand and grapple with,
but there are other
categories we underestimate,
like certain types of minds
that correspond to personalities
that don't sell well in election,
and so I worry that we're still
gonna end up with very biased
groups of people in power,
and I think we are losing out on the power
of greater diversity that way
that would also be a
lot more, again, tired,
so that's my worry,
and then, I would say that,
this is perhaps a question to Mark,
I worry about the transparency
of this scheme, which
is quite complicated,
do we not lose some democratic appeal
when we have these multiple steps
and there's some elections,
some random selection,
don't people lose
the chain of accountability
in those schemes?
- Yeah, Mark, please answer.
- I actually think that this can be,
you can still have quite
a bit of accountability
because, I mean, right now,
I mean, we elect all sorts of
horrible elected officials,
and I don't think you
hardly ever see anyone
who feels particularly bad
because they cast a vote,
I mean, no one really feels
any ownership of any decision,
I mean, so certainly the
process that I had suggested
I intend it to be highly transparent,
so people, you know, we can see
how the deliberations
work, what the output is,
but also, then, people,
you know, a small number of people
would be very much responsible
for particular leaders,
so if that person a did a bad job,
you could go back and
say, "You group of people,
"you chose them, it's sort of your fault."
Again, nothing is perfect,
everything is imperfect,
but I do think that questioning,
and again, Helene, you're
doing that with your own work,
the idea that just somehow
polling large numbers of people
leads to a good decision,
I think that we see
the problems with that,
and so trying to find an alternative,
I think any of these solutions,
you have to try in reality
and then sort of see
what works in iterates,
I don't think anything is
perfect in the abstract
or in all contexts.
- Thank you. Rob?
- Well, I'll say one thing,
I guess I would be loath at this point
to not ground any system
in a one-person-one-vote electoral system,
so I am a big believer
that that's important,
and that's a way of sort of measuring
consent of the governed,
having this conversation,
I think there's interesting
ways to add in some ideas
that would add dimensions without,
but also, let's start by
making that dimension work
because we have so far to
go in the United States
that it's sort of easy to start there
because it is so problematic
and so, in some ways,
transparently straightforward
how to make it much, much better,
our slogan at FairVote
is A More Perfect Union,
and I think part of that choice
was the belief that
it's an ongoing process,
we're not gonna get perfection,
so no, it's not like we
get ranked-choice voting
for all of our elections and
the Fair Representation Act,
and we can just, you know, say we're done,
but it would be starkly
and importantly better,
and I think one area
that we can think about
also is sort of embracing
the fact that we have
a particularly federalized
system in the United States,
so we have about half a
million elected offices,
we have a lot of local government,
more than I think any other country,
or at least most countries,
and that there's an opportunity in there
to try to see if there's ways
that we can generate more citizen
participation and dialogue
that, in a sense,
captures some of what people
are talking about here,
but the reality is right now
people are actually less interested
in participating at that level
even though it's closer to home,
so it's something that I
think that we should work on.
Last thing I'll say,
big fan of things like
participatory budgeting,
there already are a lot
of kind of creative things
going on out there
and we just need to keep
thinking about different models
to add on to the electoral one.
- Yeah, Helene?
- Yeah, I just wanna
reply to the point that,
if we care about one-person-one-vote,
we have to stay with elections,
I don't think so, we can
have one-person-one-vote
used in the context of referenda
and, you know, all kinds
of mass popular voting,
what I object to is not the
one-person-one-vote principle,
which is, of course, essential
and would be a part of an open democracy,
but the use of that just to select people
who then exercise power on our behalf,
I think we should be using
this one-person-one-vote right
to make decisions ourselves
based on the recommendations
of a randomly selected body or directly.
It's not a real choice.
- And one thing I think makes
a big difference in the U.S.
is just the closed primaries
in so many different states
that influence who gets there,
even in places with the
same electoral system,
you see that having a huge difference.
Anyway, let's open it
up now to the audience,
there is a huge wealth of
knowledge and experience
and cases that they know about
in terms of the audience,
so first we'll go to Caity Welz, Caity?
- [Caity] Hi, my name's Caity Welz,
I'm a government teacher in
Springfield Massachusetts.
I have a couple questions,
but I'm gonna start with one for Rob
just in case I only get the one, (laughs)
I think one of the fears
in switching up the way that
we vote is that safe states,
whether they are red or blue,
by taking steps to make
their elections more fair
could give an advantage to
what's seen as the other side
by taking the safety
out of their elections,
while states that don't adopt the measures
retain those safe seats,
so there's two parts to my question,
do you think there's a way to avoid
this unintended consequence?
And if the change was to
be implemented nationwide,
do you think there's a way to do it
within the confines of the
Constitution as it exists now
given that states may
throw in electoral rules
since it seems unlikely that
we would see an amendment
to increase voter fairness
given the lack of incentive
for existing congresspersons
to jeopardize their positions
by removing the safety of their seats?
- Well, that's a good
question, and I'll say,
I saw as part of your chat question too
about ranked-choice voting
having lost in the
ballot in Massachusetts,
the good news was that's the only time
it's lost in the ballot
in the last five years
and it's been on the ballot
in more than 15 other jurisdictions,
then including cities,
it's won by an average
of more than two to one in every city
voting on it for a while,
so it doesn't mean you can
throw it on the ballot everywhere and win,
but there's a lot of sort of
I think interest for change,
and the more we use it, I
think the better it can look.
For Congress, you know, you're
right about the challenge of,
how do you have one state be fair and not,
you see it play out
when people talk about
redistricting reform,
and, you know, like, "Well, if we have
"kind of a better redistricting process,
"a fair one,
"that might mean more competition
"and turnover of incumbents in our state,"
and the other states don't,
then you know, nationally,
that's actually not fair,
even if it's fair in the state,
but a lot of states have
moved ahead anyway on that,
so that isn't a barrier to
change happening state by state.
There is a requirement for House
elections that's statutory,
that's important, it's a federal statute,
most recently passed in 1967
after not having been
in place for a while,
which is to require
single-member districts,
so this is a,
the early congresses had a
lot of multi-member districts
at large elections for Congress,
and when a 1929 law that
was sort of associated
with also capping House size,
kind of ridiculously at 435
rather than having an ongoing conversation
about increasing the House,
it opened the door to
multi-member districts,
and some states were
doing that in the '60s,
so anyway, Congress said,
"Well, let's have everyone
be quote-unquote fair
"by having single-member districts,"
that isn't actually super fair,
as we demonstrated,
and mostly noncompetitive races
and a lot of gerrymandering
going on in a bunch of states,
and so the theoretical basis
of the Fair Representation Act,
which is statutory,
doesn't require changing the Constitution,
is to say, well, let's actually
have states be truly fair
and all simultaneously put
in multi-member districts
with a ranked-choice system
and have those benefits
that I talked about.
So the politics of that are big and bold,
I think, grounded in the logic,
that that's a good way to do it,
but there's other approaches
that may end up being the way it goes,
which is sort of allowing states,
again, to have the option to do it,
and it goes more sort of state by state,
but we're sort of
launching the conversation,
and we're doing it in a climate
where we really need to do something,
and that's, I think, the
impetus for Congress,
they're kind of stuck in a situation
that a lot of them feel
very challenged by,
and I think that even if
their own seats are safe,
operating in Congress to
get things done is not safe,
or it's sort of hard for them to do
what they actually wanna
do a lot of the times,
and that creates, I think, the opportunity
to actually get the big changes
that are usually really hard to win.
- Okay, Caity, you get one more
because you have questions
for a number of the other
people, so pick one.
- [Caity] Okay, oh, thank you so much
for letting me ask another one.
For Helene, what other
criticisms of jury selection
in some areas of the United
States, including Connecticut,
has highlighted the
potential bias in selection
based on the data that they're
generating their lots from,
could you comment on that?
And do you have any suggestions
about how that could be
avoided in your proposal?
- So that's a fair criticism,
I'll tell you what the French did,
which sounds like, it seemed
to me, like a decent solution,
they had to select 115 citizens,
so what they did is that they generated
300,000
randomly generated phone numbers,
it was a private company that did that,
and then they called the people
and gathered their demographics
and asked questions,
and then they applied
court assembly to that,
and then in the end, they,
so the criteria were age,
gender, education level,
settlement, meaning whether
they were urban or rural,
geographic origin, we didn't have race
because it's not a legal
category in France,
and one thing they failed to
take into account I think,
which was, I think, a mistake,
is their opinion about climate change,
I think that would have been
important to sample as well,
but at the end, they got
190 voluntary citizens
that were, you know, not representative,
I think it's too few anyway
to represent statistically
the people of France,
but they are really diverse
and tracking the main categories
that we would care about,
and that way, they had 150
citizens at each session,
that (indistinct) it seemed
to be a decent method.
- Okay, let's call on George Linzer,
I hope that Christine
comes back in a moment.
- [George] Hi, thanks, Steven.
I am a publisher and editor
of the "American Leader,"
and my question is related
to Steven's opening question,
and first, I just wanna say
I think systems are, no
matter what the system,
it's, in a way, destined to be hacked,
and we've seen that with the
current system that we have,
and I do agree with Rob
that making a more
perfect union is the goal
and an ongoing process,
so with that in mind, my question is this,
where do you see the
role of civics education,
and by that, I'm including
mandatory service
and a nationally standardized curriculum,
as a solution to the problems we face
relative to systemic change?
And I'll let anyone who
has a thought on that,
I'd be happy to hear it.
- Okay, just put your hand up
if you have thoughts on this.
Helene, could you?
- Well, I tend to think
that a lottocratic system
has built-in civics education,
which is not just listening
to boring lectures,
it's actually doing and practicing
what we are constantly preached, you know?
So it's Socratic practice of deliberation,
and you can start in school,
you could start at the university,
you could start in your company,
you know, we've got all kinds of ways
where we could reform governance
so that people are randomly drawn
into these decision-making bodies
and learn about deliberating
with other people,
dissent, people who disagree with them,
and that forges,
also just bring into contact
people who would never meet otherwise,
you know, elected circles
tend to be very homogenous
on a number of dimensions,
when you have a random sample
and you bring together a farmer
from, you know, I don't know, Wisconsin,
and a designer from New York,
and a nurse from Minnesota, I don't know,
these are people who've
never really encountered
people like themselves,
so I think it's really important
forging a sealing bond
and, you know, bridging the gap
between a Trump voter and
a Biden voter, crucially.
- Just to add, just a
quick example of policy,
it might be other Scandinavian countries,
but definitely Norway,
they sort of take this
responsibility really seriously
that young people are
soon gonna be voters,
gonna be participants,
and there's much more
intensive civic education
than is usual in the United States,
but includes everyone going
to the national capitol
for doing what often our elite students
get to do here in the U.S.
where there's sort of a mock congress
and they get to see what Congress is like,
but they all get to do that
and they get to see the actual Congress
and, you know, get to kind
of a more hands-on feel
for what they soon are gonna be,
and certainly, I think
we need to be investing
and looking in those kinds of strategies.
- Thank you.
So I don't know if
Christine's mic is back on,
but I'll ask her question,
she said, "I like Mark Gorton's idea
"and would support this
implementation for elections
"such as president,
"but it would seem an unlikely scenario
"for smaller communities
"for offices such as mayor, et cetera,
"for you to include in a number of groups
"and the people within each
group to do capable research,
"and if representatives are
not held accountable now,
"what would need to be put in place
"for greater transparency
and less corruption
"in order for a smooth transition?"
So this gets us back to
this theme that we've got
of, maybe there are other things you need
in addition to the rules,
I'm curious how you'd respond, Mark.
- I mean, I certainly
agree that the process
that I outlined in my
slide was very heavy,
I do think the idea of
a working-group model
to select the mayor of
small towns still works,
but maybe you're taking,
you know, depending on
the size of the town,
maybe it's one working
group with eight people
who get together to choose someone
that's probably known to them
to be the mayor or something like that,
I think you really can have
a smaller-scale process,
and I really do think
that there is value to
the deliberative process,
and so this...
you know, when people talk
and challenge each other,
you will get a better output there.
I'm sorry, what was the
second part of the question?
Now I'm already, it was...
- Let me see.
- Oh, it's about holding
people accountable,
so yes, what I had proposed
is just one piece of this,
and I have ideas
for a way to rethink
large parts of our system now
where we tend to put responsibility
very heavily on elected leaders,
but if you were to take something,
for example, like the impeachment process,
I mean, right now, we have
an impeachment process
that is highly political,
and, you know, really biased,
and I don't think very many people
are all that happy with it,
but the idea that you
would have some mechanism
that under a certain threshold,
whether it's a certain set
of working groups of people
or a certain say we wanna
start an impeachment process,
and again, call together working groups
where you draw random people,
and it could be a larger
deliberative body,
I mean, there are lots of ways to do it,
but again, I think one of
the core bases to my idea
is that average people
tend to be fairly honest,
and as long as they're
not part of the system
and compromised by political
loyalties and things like that,
they will not do a perfect job,
but just doing a basically decent job
is better than what we
have, in many ways, now,
and that also bringing people together
with a specific deliberative focus
allows people to invest
the time and energy
to reach better conclusions
than the kind of very superficial way
that people form opinions
based on mass media or
whatever you have now,
so I think there are lots of
ways to include working groups,
various different deliberative bodies
to, you know, whether it's choosing,
you know, what do we want the
policy on immigration to be?
We could, again, put together some sort
of statistically valid
deliberative body to
then answer that question
and give the administrators,
you know, say, implement that
policy that's been chosen,
so I think there a lot of different ways
to reconfigure things to
both get democratic intent
and to get smarter decision-making.
- Okay, great, thanks.
Next up, we're calling on Matthew Meyers.
- [Matthew] Hi, I'm undergraduate
in Professor Landemore's class,
and I have a question for Professor Celis.
So I think it's really interesting
to compare sort of your version
of multi-winner elections
to Mr. Richie's version,
and I was wondering if,
when designing the version in Switzerland,
you considered single transferable vote?
Because it would sort of have those,
like, you've had quotas,
but that would sort of do it built-in
and incorporate other
elements like ideology
that aren't so easily categorizable.
- Yeah, thank you so
much for your question,
that's very true,
so these other types of systems,
like single transferable vote,
end up with much more
representative committees,
I was thinking of it
in terms of committees,
but panels or groups of people.
It does it via a very different mechanism,
and I think both approaches
have different strengths and weaknesses,
and which you might wanna use
in a given context would matter,
I think you absolutely
identified the benefit
of a single transferable
vote method in that it's,
you don't need these specific or rigid.
- Yeah, it's frozen,
so we'll hope that Elisa
comes back in a second.
Let me see-
- I might just add
a comment on that,
just because I'll be intrigued
to get more of the specifics
of what happened in Switzerland,
but there are ways to combine
single transferable vote
with some kind of guaranteed outcomes
by gender or other categories,
and it's an intriguing opportunity
that actually single
transferable vote permits
within a proportional system,
so anyway, I'll be interested in hearing
more about the way it was
done there in Switzerland.
- Yeah, Elisa, you froze briefly,
so let's go again.
- Yeah, so sorry about that,
my internet cut out and I
have no idea what you heard
or what you didn't hear,
so I'll try to not,
hopefully, this isn't
all repetition for you.
What I was saying is
that it's both systems
are approaching the same problem,
like, how do we get a
representative electoral body,
through very different mechanisms,
and what I was saying is
that which one you might want
in a particular context would vary,
so I don't think one is
strictly better than the other.
The difference is kind of
the mechanism that is used
and results when a
single transferable vote,
what I was saying, as Matthew
very clearly identified,
that one of the huge benefits
is that it kind of implicitly
gets this diversification
and doesn't need these
rigid separate categories
as to how many women
or how many people from
such-and-such category,
and I think that is a huge value
because it does allow you
to get all these other
more implicit categories.
I would say the downside is that,
while overall, you get
more diverse committees
or more representation,
it's not guaranteed,
and if you have groups of people
that are very underrepresented
in the overall population
but still deserve, rightly, a voice,
it generally is not enough
to get enough votes on
those candidates, right?
Or it might not be enough,
depending on the particular context,
so by actually setting
up these strict rules,
you lose something in that brittleness,
but you also gain something
by first having a guarantee
that you're actually going to get
that desired representation
and making sure that all
parts of your population
are represented.
- Thank you.
Shyam Sunder, is Shyam there?
- [Shyam] Can you hear me?
- Yes.
- [Shyam] Okay.
So the behavior of elected representatives
has long been debated,
what they actually choose to do
or whether they represent,
they actually behave in a way
that represents the constituent interests
or the assessment of a general will,
a general good for society,
or something else, an
interest of their own,
my question is, how do you
think your respective proposals
might affect the behaviors
of elected representatives?
- Okay, we'll call on people
in the order in which they present
if they would like to speak,
and if they don't, they don't have to,
so Elisa.
- Yes, so I think there's a
explicit way in which it changes
in that if you have a more
diverse representative body,
you just, by nature, have to
tackle problems differently
because you can't conveniently ignore
a huge part of the population
you're supposed to be representing,
but I think the other effect that we saw
when doing this in Switzerland
was that it was by far the
most diverse set of candidates
that we had seen in several years,
so I think part of what implicitly happens
when you set up alternative
systems of governance
is that you (indistinct)
people who might otherwise
be disillusioned,
who might otherwise say,
"Okay, there's no way I have
"any chance of winning this election,"
they participate as well,
so that's one way in which,
kind of both explicitly and implicitly,
the conversation shifts,
and you end up getting people
with different interests, perhaps,
or different motivations to be there
and to be part of the process
than you would otherwise have.
- Yeah, I think it's a very good question,
and this, the problem of politicians
being motivated by their own
interests has really been,
you know, is kind of a very important,
in my thinking as I try
to design my system,
I mean, because at least right now,
and again, my experiences
are very much New York-based,
but I think that they're,
what we see here is common elsewhere,
but the dominant political
forces in New York are unions,
real estate interests, the
government contractors,
and if you look at how the system works,
it's basically to benefit those interests
because those interests are able to pay,
directly or indirectly or
through blocks of votes
or things like that,
the various politicians,
and the politicians are
acting in their interest
and not the interest of the public,
and I think you see that all over,
so I very much tried to create a system
where you don't have
these outside interests
having very much direct sway
over the government officials,
the flip side of that is that
there is less accountability,
and so that is why I do
think it is important
if we were to adopt my system
to have these sort of parallel systems,
which I talked about with sort
of separate working groups
to provide some sort of
accountability there,
but at least for me,
this idea of interest of the politicians
is really core to everything
because, at least for me, it
doesn't necessarily matter
what a particular government
official looks like
or which group they represent
if they're really just
representing themselves
and whatever interest is
capable of buying them off,
and so I think this idea
of minimizing corruption
is a completely parallel set of issues
in addition to increasing
diversity and representation.
- Thank you. Helene?
- Yes, I think it's a
really good question,
I don't know how to answer,
but my suspicion is that it
really realign their behavior
with the common interests
and the public interest,
at least to a degree,
because what I observed,
even in the context
of the French Citizens'
Convention for Climate,
which was, you know, purely advisory,
is that they had, the
parliamentarians had to,
and the government had to
take into account this input
and it had to justify themselves publicly
as to why they ignore certain proposals,
and that creates a form of
deliberative accountability
that is then, you know, these
arguments are mediatized
and journalists can press questions,
it becomes harder for the
elected parliamentarians
to stay stuck in partisan logics
and ignore what the larger public
represented by this
mini-public arguably wants,
so I think it's for the better.
- Rob?
- So I think the questioner
gets at sort of what
the organizing principle
of my presentation was,
that we have to change incentives,
and I think these two proposals do.
Give a couple little
examples for each one,
so the ranked-choice ballot,
by just giving people backup preferences,
just means that you now, as a candidate,
have this different incentive
to talk to more people,
you particularly see this,
again, in nonpartisan
or primary elections,
you will see regularly
the winners say, "Gosh,"
or losers too,
you know, "this was really interesting,
"I mean, I just threw out the playbook
"that you just talk to
your base and swing voters
"and talked to everybody
"and just looked for a connection," right?
Which is what you want, I think,
and that just comes from,
the voter knows that they now have
a second or third choice
that could matter,
and so they need to think
more about candidates,
and the candidate knows that,
and then, ultimately, as a representative
just has learned a lot
more about the people there
that they're gonna represent.
Not the be all and end all,
but a clearly just sort of step forward.
The multi-member district,
particularly with a proportional system,
and these are these candidate-based,
American-style kind of forms
of proportional voting,
we've had some examples of them,
the two really kind of
clearest differences
are that every representative
will share constituents
with someone from a different party,
so you have a different reason
when you're sort of
serving your constituency
to talk with people of another party
because you actually
share a representative,
you know, you share constituents,
and when the parties
retreat to their caucuses,
they kind of bring the whole country
or the whole state into the room,
and the interests of cities
are part of Republican caucuses
and of rural areas are part
of Democratic caucuses,
and so the attentiveness of both caucuses,
major parties at least,
to be kind of thinking about
the whole country changes,
and of course, the ranked-choice feature
kind of creates different opportunities
to be rewarded for sort
of solving problems
for at least some representatives,
that's what they will be in office for,
and they can get reelected to do that.
- So thanks to all the panelists
for offering fresh ideas and insights
on a perennial question,
how do we get better representation
and, hopefully, better outcomes?
A reminder just to visit the ISPS website,
isps.yale.edu, keep up with events,
you can also join our mailing list
to receive a monthly newsletter,
event information on future events,
or follow us on Twitter and Facebook,
and lastly, just a big
thank you to the organizers,
Pam Greene, Pam Lamonaca,
Tory Bilski, and Limor Peer,
as well, of course, to all
the people in the audience
who asked such great questions
and participated so much.
So thank you very much, and
we'll see you at the next event.